>> Tucker: AFTER WEEKS OF
MUCH HYPE AND THEN FALSE
REPORTS THAT IT HAD BEEN
STOPPED, THE INFAMOUS
CARAVAN OF CENTRAL AMERICAN
MIGRANTS HAS ARRIVED AT THE
U.S.-MEXICO BORDER.
HUNDREDS HAVE ARRIVED AT
MAKESHIFT SETTLEMENT IN
TIJUANA RIGHT ACROSS THE
BORDER FROM SAN DIEGO.
SOME MAY PLAN TO SNEAK
ACROSS.
OTHERS PROTECT THEMSELVES AT
THE POINT OF ENTRY AND
DEMAND ASYLUM IN THIS
COUNTRY.
WILL IT WORK?
HOW DOES THAT WORK.
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF ICE AND
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> Tucker: WE KNOW THIS
GROUP HAS BEEN COMING.
WE HAVE BEEN WATCHING ON
VIDEO FOR WEEKS NOW.
WOULD IT BE POSSIBLE, LEGAL
TO SAY YOU ARE NOT
RESIDENTS.
HAVE YOU NO LEGAL RIGHT TO
COME IN.
NO YOU CAN'T CROSS THE
BORDER.
>> COUPLE THINGS TO DO.
IF THEY ARE REALLY SEEKING
ASYLUM, THEY JUST PASSED
THROUGH A SAFE NATION OF
MEXICO.
IF IT'S A MATTER OF LEAVING
GUATEMALA HONDURAS.
WENT THROUGH MEXICO THEY CAN
CLAIM ASYLUM THERE.
I DON'T KNOW IF THIS IS AS
MUCH CLAIM ASYLUM OR GETTING
TO THE UNITED STATES.
>> Tucker: CLEARLY A SCAM,
OBVIOUSLY.
WE KNOW THAT BUT WHAT CAN WE
DO ABOUT IT?
>> CONGRESS NEEDS TO TAKE
SOME ACTION.
WE SENT A LIST OF
LEGISLATIVE FIX LOOPHOLES
THEY NEED TO ADDRESS.
FOR INSTANCE, THE TREASURE
HOLDS ON CLAIMING FEAR ARE
SO LOW.
NEARLY 90% OF PEOPLE CLAIM
FEAR WILL GET A YES FROM CIS
BECAUSE THE THRESHOLDS ARE
SO LOW.
THEN THEY GO SEE A JUDGE IF
THEY EVER SHOW UP TO SEE A
JUDGE.
THOSE APPROVALS ARE MUCH
LOWER LIKE 30%.
WE NEED TO FIX THAT AND MOVE
THOSE HEARINGS UP IN FRONT
OF IMMIGRATION JUDGE SO THEY
HAVE THAT FORMAL HEARING.
MOST OF THEM DO NOT GET FEAR
FINDING BECAUSE THEY DON'T
HAVE A CREDIBLE CASE TO
PRESENT.
THEY NEED TO BE QUICKLY
REMOVED.
>> Tucker: HOW DOES IT WORK?
ANYBODY CAN SHOW UP AT THE
BORDER WITHOUT PAPERS AND
SAY "I'M IN HERE FOR MY LIFE
OR I'M AFRAID IN SOME WAY
AND THEN THEY ARE LET INTO
THE UNITED STATES?
>> WELL, THEY WILL BE HELD
AND INTERVIEWED.
FAMILY UNIT WE HAVE A NINTH
CIRCUIT DECISION THAT CAN
SAY WE CAN ONLY DETAIN
FAMILY UNITS UP TO 20 DAYS.
THEY CAN'T POSSIBLY HAVE A
HEARING IN FRONT OF A JUDGE
THAT QUICK SO THEY
EVENTUALLY ARE RELEASED.
>> Tucker: NEWT UNITED
STATES?
>> YES.
WE HAVE ASKED CONGRESS TO
LOOK AT THAT.
IT'S CALLED THE FLORIDA
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT.
WE WANT THEM TO ADDRESS THAT
LEGISLATIVELY.
IF THEY CLOSE THESE LOP
HOLES WE CAN CONTROL THE
BORDER.
LAST YEAR 45% -- 45-YEAR LOW
IN BORDER CROSSINGS BECAUSE
THIS PRESIDENT HAS TAKEN
BORDER SECURITY SERIOUSLY.
ICE FINE MEN AND WOMEN OF
BORDER PATROL DO THE JOB.
NOW THE SMUGGLERS FIGURE OUT
THE LOOPHOLES AND USE THEM
AGAINST US.
CONGRESS NEEDS TO ACT AND
CLOSE THESE LOOPHOLES SO WE
CAN DO OUR JOB AND SECURE
THE BORDER.
>> Tucker: AS LONG AS YOU
CLAIM FEAR YOU CANNOT BE
IMMEDIATELY DEPORTED YOU ARE
RELEASED INTO THE UNITED
STATES.
>> IF YOU CLAIM FEAR AND YOU
GET INTERVIEWED AND CAN YOU
PASS A VERY LOW THRESHOLD
OF -- AND MOST THESE PEOPLE
BEING TRAINED AND TAUGHT
WHAT TO SAY BY GROUPS DOWN
IN MEXICO, COME IN AND MAKE
THAT CLAIM.
WE CANNOT REMOVE YOU.
THOSE CLAIMS HAVE TO BE
ADJUDICATED.
>> Tucker: WE ARE BASICALLY
HELPLESS.
WE HAVE HAMSTRUNG OURSELVES
IT SOUNDS LIKE?
>> AGAIN, IF WE FIX THE
LOOPHOLES, WE WOULD BE IN A
LOT BETTER POSITION.
FOR INSTANCE, THE ADULTS WE
ARE DETAINING UNTIL THEY SEE
THE JUDGE.
THE FAMILY IS THE BIG ISSUE.
THAT'S WHAT MOST OF THESE
ARE FAMILY UNIT OR CHILDREN.
WE HAVE CERTAIN COURT
DECISIONS THAT LIMIT WHAT WE
CAN DO.
HOW LONG WE DETAIN THEM.
THAT'S WHAT NEEDS TO BE
FIXED.
WE PRESENTED THAT TO
REPRESENTATIVES ON THE HILL
MONTHS AGO.
SO, IF THEY REALLY WANT TO
ADDRESS THIS MIGRATION THEY
CAN SIMPLY HELP NEWS CLOSING